has tweeted out by Nicole Snooki policey
Snooki Snooki told me that's literally
Wanna Cry what is happening at the UFO
hearing history
finally the public get to hear what
we've all known and thought Snooki I'm
with you I've been thinking it
to the Congress today the United States
of America the number one country in the
world they announce aliens are real yeah
this is all very scary oh my God look at
this a former Air Force officer and
intelligent official told Congress
Wednesday he believes the government is
hiding captured UFOs and claimed he
could not reveal whether anyone was
murdered to keep the secret contained
okay there's literally life everywhere
and we don't know about all bets are off
now imagine literally like in the 2024
election it's you know Biden Trump or
DeSantis and then there's an octopus